The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare@mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Any issues with
the project so far?
Have you gotten your
repositories set up and the
compiler works and all this?
So I'm glad to see a
lot of people are
getting a early start.
In fact, if you haven't, a lot
of other people in the class
are getting an early start
so you're behind already.
So go there, get the project
started, because these
performance projects can
run for long time.
And in fact, last year a lot of
people asking, when is my
project done?
Because a lot of times when you
have a project there's a
certain set of--
we ask you to implement.
Once that's implemented,
the project is over.
But when is a performance
project done?
And the only answer I L when the
deadline comes because you
can always shave 10% here,
you can get a better data
structure, you can
keep like kind of
tweaking for a long time.
And a lot of you will do.
In fact, to give you a warning,
last year, the
performance difference between
the best project won, versus
the worst one, even the worst
one got about 50% better than
the code we gave.
But the best one got 1,000x
better than the worst one
because they figured out right
data structures, they changed
algorithms, they did some
precomputation, they did a lot
of cool stuff, and so there's
a lot to get if you do this
project right.
So just don't be happy if you
just got 10%, 50%, and say,
yeah, I got some performance.
Think carefully.
There's a lot of room in
this project for you to
gain, so work hard.
I'm not saying this
yields 1,000x.
I don't know.
I haven't exactly seen all the
things you can do, but there
could be a huge thing
you can win.
So think through not just small,
low hanging fruit, but
there could be interesting
things you can do that can
have impact.
So today what I am going to do
is talk a little bit about
basics of performance
engineering.
Kind of things you guys
would probably
know, rules to follow.
So to start that if you look at
performance engineering, it
can fit into a couple
of classes.
One is you want to get a maximum
out of the compiler
you have, the processor you
have, the system you have, you
want them running efficiently.
So if you look at the matrix
multiple examples we did this
in the first class it's saying,
OK, we have a system,
we have this very well known
algorithm, very long piece of
code, and we want to get the
best out of that thing, how do
you go about doing that?
That's mainly the focus there.
Then when you we looked at
the bithacking stuff that
Professor Leiserson did last
time, it's mainly about really
changing the algorithms.
We basically said, OK, look, if
we're thinking about this
as bits there might be
fundamental different ways to
approach this problem.
By doing that we can actually
get really good performance.
OK, we'll be doing
more of that.
Today we are going to focus on
this two middle criteria.
What we are going to do is we
are going to stay within the
spirit of the program
that was given.
Even though we are going to
change the program a little
bit, we are not going to
fundamentally change what the
program does.
So the same computations would
be done basically on the same
day but what we will do is we
will change certain aspects
how it's being done to gain some
performance advantages.
So the nice thing about this
one is you don't have to
really understand the algorithm,
you don't have to
understand lot of what's going
on in, what's implementation.
This is more--
you can do this as a
mechanism sub out.
The unfortunate thing is there's
not theory in these
type of engineering.
There's not something we
can prove, here's the
optimal you can do.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] nice there.
So normally performance
programming basically knows
that you need to understand
everything that's in modern
performance.
That means all the way from high
level algorithms, every
layer in the systems, the
compiler, the hardware, the
disks, all those things can
impact performance.
So it's normally when in
performance to understand
everything that
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
This is very different from
a lot of what you
guys are used to.
It is staying within
one layer.
You say, OK, this is my
layer, I don't care
what's on any of it.
I don't know care much about--
I'm going to work on that.
And the thing that normally
comes and bite you is the
other layers that you just
take for granted.
In performance it's basically
going through end to end.
That's the normal thing.
And normally, if you are an
experienced performance
engineer, you know when
the problems show up.
And you can kind of have a basic
understanding, here are
the kind of places where they
have performance problems.
And so a good performance this
is where experience comes in.
So instead of saying looking at
the code and say I have no
idea what's going on, you can
say, let me think about this,
this is where normally
something goes wrong.
And then you have to have the
skill to zoom in and identify
the problem fast.
And most of performance
engineering is basically a
good dose of common sense.
So have kind of a good
person who can
do really good debugging.
Is you have kind of a built in
algorithm how do you go about
doing something.
And a lot of times you know
your strengths, kind of
mistakes you make, you look at
those things first, and the
same way performance engineering
there has to be
kind of a back of your
head algorithm.
And hopefully at the end of
this class you're going to
develop that.
And in this lecture what I'm
trying to do is come up with a
set of rules, that kind of
patterns that occur regularly,
mistakes lot of people make,
and that can have a
substantial performance impact,
or performance gain if
you do that.
If you have done the design
patterns lectures in 005, yes,
you do, you will see
some similar ideas.
What you're doing is kind of
say, OK, here's a bunch of
patterns in there,
what we can do.
So what I'm doing is I am
following some very
interesting set of rules that
was developed by this guy
named John Bentley.
He wrote a book called
Programming Pearls, I guess.
It's a very old book, last
published in 1990.
It talks about a lot of the
small, interesting things you
can do to get really
good performance.
It's out of print.
This is probably one
reason to probably
go to library probably.
Libraries have this copy but you
can't get it on Amazon or
online so that's unfortunate.
But what I'm going to do is
I'm going to kind of read
through it and some of these
rules, modified to suit the
current program and practices.
So he looked at it and said
there are basically two kinds
of things you can do,
we can modify data,
you can modify code.
And then went down more into
details, if you modify data
you can do three things.
You can pay one against other,
you can pay by space and gain
time, you can pay from time and
gain space, and there's
sometimes, if you're lucky, you
have a win-win situation
when you can get both space
and time advantage.
So let's go through a couple
of those things.
So if you [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
by space for time, there
are four things.
I'm going to go through all
this four data structure
augmentation, storing
precomputed results, caching,
and lazy evaluation.
So what's data structure
augmentation?
So here what you want to do is
you have a data structure that
you keep the data.
You add some extra information
to your data structures.
That can mean the common
operations run much quicker.
OK?
And when this is good, because
what do you want to do is this
adding this information
has a clear benefit.
Calculating additional
information has to
be cheap and easy.
So you don't want a situation
where we have this
information, you've spent all
this time calculating this
additional information and
you're not using it that much,
or the use doesn't give you
that much advantage.
So you have amortize
the cost in here.
And then also keeping that
information current can't be
too difficult, because
sometimes you can add
information into a data
structure that makes it very
hard to make sure that that
information is kept up to
date, and then you're spending
more time and you're
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
that.
So a couple of quick
examples in here.
Something like if you have a
single link list, if you are
doing a lot of deletion it's a
very expensive proposition
because you might had to walk
through the entire list to
delete an element.
But if you are in a doubly
linked list, a division
operation is basically
order one instead of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So suddenly you realize, I'm
doing a lot of deletions,
suddenly I can say I'm adding
this additional information to
my link list, I'm maintaining
point as to both directions,
make this one operation
run much faster.
This is a very classic example
of adding additional
information.
Another one is what we call
reference counting.
So assume I have objects
somewhere and I want to figure
out who points to me.
In terms of garbage collection
you want to see if anybody
points to me.
The normal way to do that is
look for every other thing
saying is anybody pointing to
that person, had to walk
through every possible object
out there to find if anybody's
pointing to this object.
That's what normal garbage
garbage collectors do.
But there's something
easier, what you
call reference counting.
That means if each object keep
a count on the amount of
pointing coming to itself then
to ask that question, is this
really true?
And you look and say,
OK, what's my count?
If there's count to zero
nobody's pointing to me.
But of course every time you
point to that object to update
the counter, every time you
point away or take away an
object that points you have to
subtract the counters, you had
to keep that information
additional.
But by doing that discussion
about asking whether anybody
points to you becomes a
very trivial question.
So here's a case you add a
little bit more information
and that makes some questions,
some things you want to know
trivial and very easy to do,
and you have to figure out
where the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is.
So here's one interesting
thing.
Go a little bit further,
one thing you can do is
precompute, result
and storage.
What you are doing is you want
some calc computation and
instead of every time you want
that in recalculating it, say,
OK, I'm going to compute them
early and I'm going to store
it somewhere, and then every
time I want then I
just do a look up.
So when is this going
to be useful?
So this is--
the rest of my slides are going
to have this kind of
form, I'm going to give you a
problem, tell you when it's
going to be useful, and
use some examples.
First of all, the function you
are calculating has to be
somewhat expensive, otherwise if
it is just a simple single
operation look up is probably
too slow to compile.
And the function has to be very
heavily used, because if
you are calling it many, many
times it's worth storing it.
Another very important
thing is the argument
space has to be small.
You might be asking for calling
the function millions
and millions of time, but every
time you call you give a
different set of arguments.
If the arguments are very large
it can be many, many
things here, and then it's not
easy to store everything.
And it might take more time to
find all the solutions for all
the arguments.
So if the arguments
have to be small.
And of, course, a couple
additional things, results
only depends on the arguments.
So assume the function results
actually look time of day to
the computation.
OK, that doesn't work, because
then every time you call the
function, you get different
result.
That doesn't work that much.
And functions shouldn't
have side effects.
What that means is if you call
the function, if it is
modifying some global variable,
global state.
OK.
Then if you keep the call, if
you don't call the function
that might not happen, so you
want to make sure that this
function is something can not
call and give the results and
the state of the system
won't change.
And another interesting, nice
thing to have is function
determinants, that means every
time you call the function you
get the same four arguments,
you get the same results.
So this is a long list.
Some of the things I will go,
so for an example, OK, so
instead of me getting there
getting all the things I want,
you [INAUDIBLE]
when I give a prescription like
the thing, what kind of
things can I do in this way
that might be helpful?
Can anybody come up with
an interesting example?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
would precompute and save.
AUDIENCE: Anytime you do
dynamic programming.
PROFESSOR: Anytime you
dynamic program.
This is dynamic programming,
it's a very good way, later we
probably go get a little
bit into that.
Where you precompute
and save results.
OK, that's very sophisticated
answer.
Good.
Any other things you
can think of?
That's almost a meta answer
that's in that class of things
you can do.
Any problem there that you have
encountered that you'd
rather precompute and save that
would be a big, big win.
AUDIENCE: Operations with large
primes that [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Operations with?
AUDIENCE: Large primes.
PROFESSOR: Large primes,
operations in
large primes, yes.
If you are doing that,
especially if this fits into
this argument space
small apart.
If the large primes are, any
large primes then you might
not call it multiple times.
So here I want to give you kind
of a template that what
happens here.
So what you want to do is at
initialization time I get this
function initialized, what I
do is I precompute for all
arguments what the results are
stored at, and then every time
you go apply the function I
just basically, instead of
calling the function, I just
look at this table.
OK.
So then would this
be a bad idea?
AUDIENCE: Because you know this
early ahead of time you
know that you're going to be
calling the function for all
of your arguments.
PROFESSOR: So if the argument
space is very large or if you
don't call the function that
many times, or as I said, it
might only call for very small
number of arguments,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
this might not be a good idea.
OK?
So we will go.
As we improve, you'll see some
other things that actually
address that.
So here's an interesting way of
doing a use case in here.
So what I have here is
Pascal's Triangle.
How many people know
Pascal's Triangle?
OK, good, so I don't have
to explain that.
So here is a simple computation
for Pascal's Triangle.
So what I'm doing is in order
to calculate this value I am
calling these two values
and adding that.
OK?
But the problem is that this
will call- so it kind of call
exponentially more and
more doing that.
So you'd say exponential
rhythm.
However, what I can do in
Pascal's Triangle is I can
basically compute it at the
beginning by storing the
previous role, or previous set
of values in and then previous
role, and every time I'm calling
I just basically have
to look up the two elements
in the previous role.
Trying to get my mouse, OK.
Only have to look at the two
elements on the previous role.
I added up, I will never have
to compute beyond that.
So, in fact, by just doing
this one I have taken
exponential algorithm to
basically lead a path through
the data, basically.
This actually become a square,
because if you have some
depth, I had to do i squared--
become a square, pass
through the data.
If I'm looking for n, I
don't know how to do
exponential look up.
Everybody saw this?
So this is a nice way, simple
way I'm just doing a simple
storing this data, however in
here I had to calculate, I
need to know how much maximum
of that, and calculate and I
just look up.
And here the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
if you calculate a little bit
extra, who cares, I'm OK.
And another interesting
thing is Fibonnaci.
And again, here, if you do
keeping the previous value, in
here, you're actually changing
from exponential algorithm, to
in here basically a linear
calculation.
OK?
So this is almost an algorithmic
change here.
I kind of lied when
I said it's just a
data structure change.
But just a simple data structure
change made an
algorithm difference.
So the other interesting thing
you can do is caching.
So what that means is if you
have a heavily used function
you can keep some number of
previous basically results
from calling that function.
This has a lot of caveats
so let's go
through this carefully.
Again the function has to be
expensive, otherwise it's not
worth doing all that work.
Functions have to be heavily
used, otherwise you're
calculating and if you don't
reuse it it's not worth doing
all the worth.
Here the arguments space can be
large, OK, because you are
not calculating everything, you
can have a large argument
space, and that's OK.
And then there's another thing
called temporal locality.
Anybody knows what temporal
locality means?
OK what.
AUDIENCE: The same arguments are
called [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so a lot of
times we realize that if you
go into the caching and
stuff like that.
We really get into that in
hardware when you talk about
hardware lecture.
So what happens is yes, we have
observed that if I have a
set of arguments and if I
calculate most of the times I
will have the same arguments
very quickly time-wise.
So if I calculate something,
then for a short time I might
reuse those arguments again and
again, so that's called
temporal locality.
So caching works when there's a
very good temporal locality.
And then there's two other
things we want to do because
we won't have hash function that
means because a lot of
arguments from that we only get
one value to look up where
I store my cache, have to have
a hash function, but to
calculate it by argument.
Sometimes if the arguments are
too complicated you might not
be able to calculate a good
hash function and the hash
function has to be good.
What do you mean by a
good hash function?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, no
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
That means they tend to be
a good distribution.
So given most of the arguments
it shouldn't be ending up as
the same value again, so you
should have good distribution
when you call with different
arguments.
And the final results only
depend on the arguments that's
again otherwise you have a
problem and the function
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
if your [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
this important.
And there's another thing
called coherence.
So what that means
is I keep some
precalculated values in here.
And sometime this if results
are only dependent on the
arguments you don't have
that much of an issue.
But sometimes you might in the
situation that the results are
dependent on the arguments and
some other things like the
time of the day or whatever.
And if you want full coherence,
what you want to
make sure is--
many of you know that the
results might be varied.
I need to understand
that, I need to
invalidate all the cache.
And suddenly the data or the
user changed so that thing I
memorized only works for User
A, now went to User B, the
results are wrong and I had to
get rid of all the results.
Or there are some cases where
you could say, yeah, little
bit of things I can tolerate,
like for example, a really far
fetched example is something
like if you're looking at a
web page on a search.
OK, you don't have a good
guarantee that all the web
pages in the world are
in that search.
If you're a little bit late
getting a new web
page, then you're OK.
So you can do tolerate
sometimes, a lot of times, if
you can tolerate these kind of
things you can have huge
performance impact.
You don't have to be exact.
So some of these projects we
look we look at these kind of
ideas, of tolerate a little bit
of a slack and getting a
good performance out of that.
So here's the kind of code, I
put a lot of code in my slides
because not I won't explain
everything but since these
online if you want to figure out
what the right template is
you can look at it.
I have no idea why this
is moving on me.
OK, OK, here we go.
So what you first have to say
is every time you cache a
value you have to know, I had
to know old arguments and
results, I had to store that,
and then I'm keeping this many
precomputed values in here.
And so every time I call the
function with arguments first
I have to see I had to get the
get the has with these
arguments because that might be
the place, this buffer disk
just might be the place I have
stored a previously computed
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Then you say, OK look, is my
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] stored, has
the same argument.
If that means I already have
that precomputed, at that
point I just return it, I
have no issue in there.
Otherwise you're to call the
function because I haven't
stored it, and then I will go
about storing the value
because I calculated I need a
storage because the next time
I call these arguments I want
to get the same results, and
then I return the result.
OK.
Is this kind of clear, how
this caching works?
OK, what's a good place for
caching versus precomputing?
Any idea what can make a good
scenario where actually
caching can have a big impact?
You have heard a lot of things
that have the word cache
associated with it, and you can
say, OK, what that means.
AUDIENCE: Web browsing.
PROFESSOR: Web browsing OK, you
web browse actually that's
a cache, because there's a good
probability that if you
look at a page and you might be
refreshing that page or you
might be looking at that page,
so a lot of times what you do
is you keep a copy locally, and
the next time you ask for
that and if you have a local
copy you can give
that local copy back.
And then of course there's some
issues about how to make
the local companies stay, the
coherence issues and stuff
like that it can get complicated
but that's a
situation where actually
you can use caching.
So finally, in this category,
we are going to talk about
lazy evaluation.
So lazy evaluation means
basically a lot of times you
might ask for value but you
might not really need it at
that point.
Just keep the computation to the
side without doing it and
then do the computations only
when you really, really need
the result.
So basically this is useful, a
lot of times you might try to
compute a lot of values but
only a certain of that
actually is used.
And at that point you just
basically further that
calculation and only use it
when it's actually done.
The nice part is when can be
done in a function call, and
also results can be calculated
kind of incrementally.
And also, the arguments or
what's needed to calculate the
results can be nicely packaged
up so it can be
recalculated later.
So here what you do here is in
the precomputing is something
like precomputing but you don't
precompute early, at the
beginning nothing
is precomputed.
When you only ask to apply a
function then if there's no
precomputed value you'll
recompute, otherwise you just
return the value.
So if you compare this one
Pascal's Triangle beforehand I
just computed, there's a bunch
of values in here and kept it.
OK assuming OK up to
PDMAX I will have
the results in there.
But you might not do that.
PDMAX might be very large and
you might be looking only for
small Pascal Triangle.
So instead of doing that, what
you can do is you can do this
way, you can keep the array for
results, assume everything
is normally in [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
global array.
and then what happens is you
look at the results if the
results is greater than zero we
are what you're looking at,
that means, ah-ha.
I have calculated it.
I have a new value, I
just iterated it.
I'm happy.
Otherwise I will call Pascal
by recalculating values
because I don't have the
current results.
And once I get it
I will store it.
Once I get the value I will
basically, I will calculate
the Pascal, I will store it and
I will return the value.
So what that means is this value
of the Pascal yx will be
only calculated once fully, and
afterward every other time
you lose that you actually
use the previous one.
This works very nice, this works
both very nice about
precomputation but you don't
pay that extra overhead.
So you are doing the minimum
amount of computation.
You can never exceed the
computation of the normal
computation.
So if you only ask for Pascal
very small one, that's exactly
the work we [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
do.
But it will also really use this
kind of exponential blow
up that happens in the
normal computation.
So this is kind of the you can
have the cake and eat it too
in this work.
OK good.
So now let's switch from space
for time, for time for space.
OK?
So here, one thing you can do
is if you have a huge amount
of data what you can do is you
can store the data in some
kind of reduced form and then
what you can do is then you
can get a big compression of
data basically and then as you
need the data you can do some
more computation to get the
data you want.
So what you're doing is you are
really reducing the space
you need but now you are paying
by time to get access
to that data.
So this is why [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
storage is at a premium.
If you look at systems before
1980s everybody had to do it
because storage was a premium
and all the memory and disk
space was so complicated
everything got
compacted in there.
Now, most your laptop and
desktops, you don't care, you
have enough space.
However, if you got things
like embedded devices and
things like that, this still
becomes a issue.
Or if you have a very large data
set it becomes an issue.
And what you can do is by
compressing, drastically
reduce the data size.
And you can do it in different
ways, sometimes you
can do it in batch.
That means you keep the data
compressed, expand it all, and
process, hopefully you
have room for that.
Or sometimes if you don't have
room you do it by streams,
that means you're looking at a
small amount of data expanded,
work at it and then either throw
it or again compress it
and put it back in.
And hardest thing is if you
actually do random access.
That means you'll randomly go
to some data, expand and
understand that sometimes
there's some complications.
So there are a bunch of packing
methods and some
simplest things are use
a small data size.
So right now you're dealing with
64 bit words, you can say
wait a minute, why does this
data only need 8 bits?
Why do you keep storing
everything 64-bit if my data
maximum can be only 0 to 256.
I can use 8 bits.
Or I can look at that and I
can use small data size,
that's something.
And a lot of people realize a
lot of data we are storing are
just zeros.
There are many different data
structures, you have huge data
structures and most
of it's zeroes.
And eliminating zeroes in many
instances can you get a long
way in many, many, many
data storage.
And something like LZ77
eliminates repetition.
So a lot of times what you
find in there you have
repetitive patterns you can
eliminate that and then, of
course, you can go into a
lot more complicated.
heavy-weight compression.
So to just give you a feel for
what compression is like I
found this cute animation so
I will show it to you.
So here is the input stream, but
it has this corrector LA,
and then it has some notion
about how much a repetition it
has, corrector O and 0 3.
So what happens if it's
just a character?
It will get taken in, so these
two correctors go.
Now these two forces from the
point I point in here go to
inwards, and repeat
it four times.
What that means is basically in
here it will get repeated
four times because that 2 4.
So that means instead of having
these four correctors
in there, what it had was it had
two things, and then all
get repeated three times and
then it'd get shifted in here.
So instead of having ten
correctors before, we had 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Seven, out of seven correctors
you compress you stored
information off ten correctors
because of repetition.
OK, so this is a very simple
scheme that people use to do
this LZ77 compression.
More complicated thing you can
do a lot of times is build an
interpreter.
What that means is you have some
complex data, instead of
storing the data you have a
summary of the data stored.
OK.
And then what you can do is
you can do this abstract
representation.
I mean you were already
tested.
Like, for example, you
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
exactly doing that.
What you do is you start off
storing all the beats of
machine instructions.
You store it in abstraction
called add register names or
something like in smd.
What that means is you're
building a very simple
abstraction which that would be
more complex sometimes to
store than the actual data.
So in here, things like if you
look at a java byte cord,
that's a nice interpreter.
So instead of storing all this
complex instructions you
interpret, you stored some
higher level set of
instructions, that byte code,
that is much more compressed
and that you run you map it into
the machine instructions.
There's a lot of advantages
other than just compressing
storage, it's a nice
abstraction, you can change it
at the highly level easily.
OK, so those are something that
you can do, you give up
one thing for the other.
And if you're lucky you can have
the cake and eat it too.
Which is you get both space
and time at the same time.
So we looked at it in last
lecture sometime.
This is bithack.
Bithacks kind of gave you that
because instead of having 64
bit word to represent you got
64 of them into one big
stream, if you're only
representing zeroes and ones.
And by doing that you get a lot
more compressed storage.
Also now you can operate that
entire 64 in parallel.
We can generalize it a little
bit, so instead of just doing
64 Boolean, sometimes you can
do in a 64 bit word, you can
store two 32 bit words,
or four 16 bit words,
so eight 8 bit words.
OK.
In [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is called a Memex
SSE extensions.
Normally it's called SIMDs, a
single instruction multiple
data, because what you do to
that, all the bits, are the
same thing for everybody.
So if you're adding you're
doing same add
for both of the data.
And because of that you
basically going to get both
the compression.
Because now for 64 bit you are
keeping two thing, or four
things, or eight things.
Also, now you're operating.
In a single operation you can
get the same operation
happening to all the data.
So you're getting both storage
and fast operations in here.
Of course if you only look at
one you have to do a little
bit more work, you take it out
of that data word, so if
you're just looking at
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
thing can be expensive.
So when is it viable?
You'll do the same operations
all the data.
OK, if each day you do something
different it's not
that great and items can be
stored in contiguous memory,
so when you load you can say I'm
getting nice in one word,
if I'm getting two 32 bit, so
four 16 bit, so I can do that.
And you don't end up picking
each operations and doing
individual things too much.
So if you are to pick each
individual elements a lot,
then you have to actually now
pick apart that word and that
can be multiple operations
and expensive.
So here's a simple example.
This, I think, from after last
bithacks class, this is a
little bit, you probably know,
can come up with enough
examples here.
What I'm doing is I'm doing
a Battleship board game.
So you represent the board, and
the interesting thing in
this board is to know whether
that location has something or
not, it's empty or full, that's
all I need to know.
And so normally if I do this
board game I can have two
boards in here.
But what I'm doing is having
this overlap calculations,
saying of the two boards,
how many things overlap.
I can just have each location
represented by integer, but
then only the representing one
value is not good enough.
One thing I can do is I can just
put each row into one 64
bit word, and then instead of
doing the two loops I can, in
one loop, I can just do the
ending off each row, and I get
the result.
So after the the bithack
lecture, this should be kind
of trivial.
OK, everybody get it?
Anybody have questions so far?
Are we all on the same page?
OK, good.
There's a lot of blank faces so
I want to help, I'll start
asking more questions
or something.
OK, so that's modifying data.
Now we're going to modifying
code, where you will change
the programs to actually get
performance and that can be
done in loops, logic rules,
procedures, expression, and
parallelism rules.
When we get to parallelism rules
we will actually do a
lot more on them in future
lectures, but I just want to
address some basic stuff now.
Bunch of different loop rules.
I will go each of them
individually.
So first of all, why loops?
Why do you think loops
are so important?
OK, somebody who hasn't
answered the question.
Why is loops so important?
Why are we like really focused
on loops all of the time?
Anyone want to answer
here, this side?
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] in terms
of maintainability,
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so loops
give you a nice, simple
abstractions it's easier to
maintain instead of having
multiple computed times.
Yes, instead of having same
thing repeated millions of
times for the same thing, if I
write a loop, it's much more
concise representation.
That's why I think we do a lot
of loops, because it makes
programs easier.
In fact, assume this word,
loops didn't exist, OK?
If loops doesn't exist that
means you're going at each
instruction get executed
only one time.
If you have a 3 gigahertz
machine that requires even if
you do one instruction per cycle
in 32 bit instruction
you need 12 gigabytes of
instruction per second, if you
only execute one instruction
once.
That means if you have 100
gigabyte disk full of a
program you go through each
instruction the entire 100
gigabytes in 8 seconds.
OK.
Of course this can never be
done, that means you cannot
feed 100 gigabytes into the
processor in 8 seconds.
That won't work because of
the disk access time,
caches, and all those.
Even if it is doable, what
that means is the entire
reason your Pentium is running
at 3 gigahertz and actually
showing like it's running as 3
gigahertz is because you are
using instructions
many, many times.
You have loops that run
millions of times.
If you don't have loops you
can use whatever the data
machine you build in '004 and
that probably as fast you
could get because of this
instruction thing.
So loops are critical, and
loops are what makes our
programs run fast.
Repeated execution of same
instruction again
and again and again.
OK.
So in the world, in that sense,
if you think about
this, unless there are some
instruction that's run
millions of times, you can
never keep this ferocious
beast's appetite full because
there will always be new
instructions.
So because of that looking at
loops, if you want to get good
performance just looking at the
most important loops, the
inner loops, and just doing only
that we'll probably get
you most of way in
many, many cases.
And basically I could even say
99 of the program execution
time is in 10% of the code,
even, more than
that in many cases.
Because otherwise
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
back of the envelope calcuation
you can do, you
realize how much code you need
to feed the beast to keep it
active otherwise.
So first loop optimization,
loop and
invariant code motion.
So normally in a loop you run
millions of times, and if you
do the same thing millions of
times and get the same results
you are just doing useless
computation.
And so here the key thing is
most of the time the compiler,
a good compiler will
come help you.
So in this class you're
not trying
to replace the compiler.
We, as humans, we want to the
least amount of work.
The compilers [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
dumb things sitting in there,
it can do most of
the hard work.
The key thing is first
trying to get the
compiler to do the work.
Only do things yourself if
the compiler cannot do.
So most of the time compiler,
if it can analyze the code,
and prove the results are the
same in each iteration, it's
going to get rid of it, it
will do that for you.
But there are cases it's not
possible because sometimes the
computation might be too costly
and also there might be
cases the computation is too
cheap if you hoist it out, you
have to keep the results in
some [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and if you keep too many things
in too many registers,
that cost might be
too expensive.
So there might be case that you
might not do, but most of
the time what happens
because the
compiler can't do anything.
So here's a good example.
I'm doing, I don't know why I
did that, but square root and
take exponential off that.
Compiler look at that
as functions.
I have no idea what the function
are most of the time.
The compiler can't tell what
each function does because the
function call.
It can do any arbitrary thing as
far as the compiler knows.
It says, OK, function call,
I don't know what happened
inside so I'm just giving up and
I'm just leaving it, but
you, on the other hand, knows
that the square root function,
exponential function doesn't
have any what you call the
side effects.
That means those functions
doesn't go
changing anything else.
It just calculates
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] the value,
you'll know this basically
calculate the same value again
and again and you can just
basically take it out, do it
twice, happy.
So lot of times make sure
the compiler can do it.
If the compiler cannot do then
you have to go in and
interfere at that point.
So here's another interesting
thing the compilers cannot do.
A lot of times you're going
through this array or data
structure looking
for some value.
OK, once you've found the value,
you will say OK, found
it, I return.
OK.
Normally what that means is when
you're going to add it,
there's two things.
First of all you had to test
whether you found the value
that you're trying to exit.
Second, you have to make sure
that you don't overrun on the
data structure, you're
not overrunning that.
you have to make sure you're not
at the end of that because
that value might not
be in that area.
If that's the case, you run
to the end of that.
So pretend I don't find it.
So you do two tests.
One thing you can do is you
start doing the two test at
the end of that array, how about
you add the value you
are testing for?
So you know when you reach to
the end you will always find
the value because you
added there, so you
know it's there already.
So by doing that you can reuse
the test by just looking for
the value because now when it
comes to the end, you don't
have to do anymore tests because
the value you're
looking is already there and
you found that, you go out.
But you should be able to add
that value to the end of that.
So what you do is this is your
normal test that's what you're
doing is you're, if I can get my
mouse, you're going through
this array, looking
for a value.
A value I return otherwise
I return minus 1 in here.
Now I do two tests.
I do this test to make
sure that I'm not at
the end of the array.
I'm [UNINTELLIGIBLE] this one.
So, in fact, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
loop I just can put the two
tests next to each other so
this is what you're doing.
But instead of doing that one
thing I can do is put that at
the end of the array, after
all the data that I care
about, I can put the value I'm
looking for and then I just
only do one test.
I check for that value.
So if you find the real
value in the area, at
that point I'm done.
Or I ran out of the array, and
after I ran out the real data
I just found the value because
I, myself, put it there.
And so I have to find it, and
the minute I find it, if I
realize that's the case I say,
OK, that's the value I put and
I [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Here I have done something
which is not really good
programming practice.
Can anybody put your 005
hat and say, that's bad
programming?
AUDIENCE: You modified
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I modified
my input array.
I know.
That's not that great.
I mean if I did it really well,
if I want to make sure
what I should have done is kept
the old value of the n
and at the end, it back
so it looks the
pristine thing I got.
I mean, if I was really careful
I would have done
that, and then my invariant that
my input array haven't
changed would hold nicely.
because here I have mucked
with my input array.
So even though you are
constantly doing performance
programming you should still
have a good eye for doing good
correct programming and keeping
nice programming
variants around than mucking
it all over the place.
So if you wonder putting a new
hat in here, you should still
have the 005 hat, at
least partially.
What else can we do?
A lot of times what you find
is we have these loops, and
loops have a couple
of features.
First of all, you have to keep
checking the loop condition,
that's expensive.
And if the loop body is very
small, the compiler doesn't
have that much opportunity to
do anything useful in the
body, just basically
compile as is.
So one thing you want to do is
if the loop bodies are too
small and the number of
iterations is small, you want
to unroll the loop.
So in here, instead of doing
this calculation again and
again, I want to actually do a
computation unrolled, and this
gives you two things.
First of all I get rid of
this disk, so I actually
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] in here.
And second, this computation can
be done much faster, the
compiler can do this much
faster than this one.
Do you see why?
Can anybody see why this
computation would happen much
faster than this doing in
the loop iteration?
AUDIENCE: Because you don't have
to write the final result
of the variable until all
the numbers [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So that's
one thing.
Even the final results in the
register what happens in here?
So that's a good assertion
but that's not
exactly what's back there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, he got 90%
of the way there.
First of all here I
had increment i.
And I have it check
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the loop condition.
That's another point in here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The one on right
can be run in parallel.
In here I am doing
sum equals--
some plus A I, so that means
I have to calculate
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Once that is done and we get the
results only then I can go
add the two, only then
I can add day three.
So the last [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
using, you can show 16
instructions at every cycle.
OK what six things you
can do in here?
Nothing.
Because you're just waiting.
You're twiddling your thumb for
the first one to finish,
to do that.
In here, you can say, look, I
don't have to add A1A to it.
I can just do these things
in parallel.
The first cycle I can
add is 0 to A of 1.
that's one instruction
2 3 2 4 5 3 6 7.
I can add all those things
together as a tree.
I can do tree addition instead
of one after another, that can
happen in one go.
And I can get a six editions
done and then the next
instruction I add the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] and at the
later stages do not have too
much to do but I could get a
lot of [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So the compiler can actually
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
all of that.
So that works very nicely if
I have small number of
iterations.
But if you have a large number
of iterations, you can still
do some stuff.
So in here what you can do is
it goes to one and you can
say, OK, I don't know.
I don't know how to unroll fully
because I don't know
what n is, but I can
unroll partially.
So here what I can do is say,
look, I have been running it n
times, I will unroll
my loop four times.
OK.
So I at least get enough
of unrolling here.
That way you can choose.
That is, you unroll enough that
the meshing can get busy.
It's not just crawling.
And then I haven't blown up my
code like crazy in here.
And of course you had to clean
up and then you have to know
how many full iterations.
So how do you choose
how much to unroll?
What impacts my number
of unrolls?
I unroll four times.
You can get greedy, and say, I'm
going to unroll 8 times,
16, 32, 64, 128.
Because a lot of time these are
not zero-sum some gains.
Some stuff impact
some other way.
So what should I use normally
for my amount of
iterations to unroll?
Anybody want to take
a guess what helps?
AUDIENCE: It's probably the
number [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so in one sense
you can look and say number of
instructions I can execute in
one cycle, that's a good thing
to keep, unroll enough to
keep the process of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] most
of the time.
But sometimes we can say oh
that's hard to figure that one
out, I don't know that because
I'm at the compiler.
I'm at high level.
I don't know what happens
at low level.
I'm going to unroll
1,000 times.
So why shouldn't I unroll
a huge amount?
What happens if I
unroll too much?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You might--
AUDIENCE: You might
to be [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, define
it more closely.
What do you mean?
AUDIENCE: Perhaps there's
some [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's the one
interesting thing.
Assume your number
of iterations
are not always millions.
Sometimes you might
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
hundred times, or 200 times.
So if you unroll 500 times,
you would never get to the
unroll loop.
You end up in this
clean up loop.
And so clean up loop, of course,
is not unrolled and so
you're back to your
square one.
And so a lot of times if you
unroll too much and if your
number of iterations doesn't
fit so you end up in here,
that's not good.
Another thing is when you unroll
loop here there's a
huge amount of instructions
now.
That instructions might be too
much, it might not fit in the
cache, it might just overwhelm
the memory system.
So you have already now created
a loop that doesn't
fit in the instruction cache
and that's not good either.
So that will limit down roll, so
don't get too greedy, just
sometimes these are the things
you kind of play with in the
problems you're looking
at and some of it is
architecture dependent.
Some of them are things like
too much unroll where the
number of iterations not that
high is problem dependent.
Another thing you can do there
are many places if you have
two different very same looking
loops we can put them
together into one loop and that
gives [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
all the loop tests and stuff
and also the array access.
At least done once, so
that can give you
a benefit in here.
Here's interesting one.
Here you have this weird loop
that the j loop run from I to
J in minus I, I to n minus I.
How can I improve this one?
Can anybody tell me what
might happen in here?
So I have outer loop I goes from
0 to N, inner loop goes
from I to N minus
I. What happen?
Somebody's getting it.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, what happens is
because what the loop is at
the beginning you're going from
basically 0 to N, and
then the lower bound is going
like this, upper bound is
going like this.
After N over 2, this is
N, N over 2, there's
no iterations left.
OK, you're trading and trading
and trading and after it
iterates, so you're running
outer loop, N over 2 to end
with nothing running
on the inner loop.
And so if you have this kind
of funky loops you can just
look at it a little bit careful
and say, wait a
minute, that's not useful.
So therefore I can just get rid
of this new situations.
And then sort of free
trading to nothing.
So that's loops rules.
Loops are very important.
also you can do a lot of
interesting logic rules.
So first of all, can anybody
shout out what each of these
things can be done?
Square root of x
greater than 0.
Square of [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
zero, sorry.
x [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Actually, not [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
sorry.
x not equal to zero.
Because x squared of
x squared non-zero.
OK.
Here's something your compiler
probably doesn't know about
the transformation.
We can do that.
How about the next one?
How can I get to input
the next one?
Square root of base climb,
looking at the distance
between x and Y and AB.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Eliminate
the square root.
It doesn't help anything you
do except do too much
computation.
OK, next one.
Yeah, I can basically multiply
and then do take a one
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
final one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: One.
OK, and then you should go and
find that program who wrote
that, but believe me you'll
find these kind of code
sitting somewhere because you
didn't think through, you just
start writing and suddenly you
have this kind of nice axiom.
So when do that this is
something compiler can do, of
for these kind of patterns.
That was a stupid mistake but
a lot of other things are
things that a compiler cannot do
but you know more than the
compiler does.
OK.
Other interesting thing in
here is if you're looking
something like [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
increasing function- OK, let
me look at this carefully.
OK, this is very similar to what
we talked before with the
[INAUDIBLE]
ending.
So one thing you can do is I can
put the cut off at the end
and then I don't have to take
check both the bounds and
basically [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
through something.
Basically this is the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
check we did done a little
bit differently.
OK.
And here's another interesting
thing.
Reordering test.
So what can you do here?
What do I do here?
I'm looking at is, I am looking
at two different a
circles, see whether they
are [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in here.
This is expensive test because
I had to do something in a
square root and check
whether it's less
than or equal to radius.
So here's what I had to do.
How can I make this faster?
What's the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in here?
So assume I have this bunch of
balls running around in my
graphics program.
I want to make sure that the
balls haven't collided.
They are actually moving with no
collision with other balls
and I'm doing this test.
What's a good [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So he's getting there
because most of the time
what happens is if you're
looking at two balls collision
most times these balls are
farther apart and if you just
found the square around the
ball, testing these two
squares are colliding
it's very cheap, OK?
And then if the squares are all
happy, then and only then
you might want to check
if actually all the
balls are all happening.
OK and by doing this square test
you can do very expensive
operations in here.
You can basically do some very
simple thing, in fact I have
even reduced it more by just
doing first doing the x side
and then if x is
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
I don't even have to check for
Y. And only if those two
checks fail that I realize,
look, the square might be now
there's a good chance it's
actually the color id.
And there's a really good chance
most of the test, after
doing the first two things,
will be done.
You'll never have to go through
this very expensive
operations.
So here's something you have a
little bit of intuition on
what's going on out there in
the problem, and use that
intuition to look like more
work, but in reality really
reduce the amount of work you
had to do because the test is
very expensive.
OK, here what I have done, OK
this is a little bit of a
contrived example, what I want
to do is assume I have
basically a 4 bit word
in here, OK.
And I am checking- this would be
8 I think, so I have 8 bit
word in here.
OK, I'm checking whether the
8 bit word is a palindrome.
So the way I check the word is a
palindrome is first of all I
set up some bits in here,
bit masks, OK?
And I have a bit mask
for the two ends.
I said, OK, these two are same,
then these two same,
these two same, these two same,
I just kind of go down
the bit mask.
Did everybody see
how this work?
And then in these two I kind
of shift my bit mask to the
side, these two, basically
shifting.
So I'm checking the most two
bits are the same, the next
two bits are the same, next two
bits are the same, going
on [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
OK, so every time I do that
I have [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
this bit mask do this operation
and stuff like that.
Assume I am checking whether
my [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
correctors.
If I call this a lot of
times what can I do?
Kind of out of the
box thinking.
So the one thing is if I am only
looking for correctors,
how many different correctors
are there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because all the
correctors in everything I
look up, I have 8 bits,
two to date.
What's two to date?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
OK, so you have 256
possibilities in here, OK.
So I'm doing this to 256 why
don't I precompute and store?
So if I just calculate for 256
different possibilities, we
see the palindrome or not, I
just store a bit for each of
them, saying it's a palindrome
or not, and then my palindrome
test is very simple.
I just look up my look up table
and say, hey, is this a
palindrome, no?
Yes?
No?
Done.
So if I'm doing this computation
a lot of times I
suddenly realize I can
precompute the kind of things
we did before.
I am very safe, I can do that.
So sometimes you have this
programs that has very
complicated control structures
but when you look at this here
you realize [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
use multiple times in here.
There's S1, if v S2, else S3.
S4 again, if v S5.
And so there re a lot of
conditions going on in here.
And something like that you can
sometimes look at that and
say, like OK, look, because
my conditions are simple.
I mean in here, I only do one,
I just do that one and I will
create the path depending
on what the
Boolean expressions are.
And even if you have two or
three conditions you can
create a couple of parts
depending on that.
So I'm replicating some
stuff, like S1 is in
both, S4 is in both.
So I have expanded my code a
lot, but now instead of having
this spaghetti code that my
compiler and my architecture
is going to stop all the time
because [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
prediction and stuff, as
Professor Leiserson pointed
out, can have issues.
I created this nice single
branch, lot of code to
execute, lot of chances for
my compiler to do a lot of
optimization.
I can say things like that.
And compiler can do it most of
the time and sometimes you
might want to help
the compiler.
Procedure rules.
So one interesting thing is a
lot of times when you have a
lot of small procedure calls.
A couple of things.
OK, let me ask you, what's the
problem with having a lot of
small procedure calls?
You cause a lot of small methods
all over the place.
What's the problem with
small methods?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
yes, because every time you do
a method call you have to
basically go change everything
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], put it back
in memory, stack, and
then go do that.
I have a basically calling
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
expensive part.
OK, so if I'm doing a very
small thing your calling
context might have a lot more
than overhead than what the
procedure does, method does.
What else?
What's a more subtle thing
that can happen?
So if you're thinking more, I'm
a compiler guy so I think
like compilers, what would the
compiler do at this point?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Compiler
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
oops, barrier, I have no idea
what's happening in here.
I had retrieved this
as just bit stop.
I will do a bunch of things
above that, I will do a bunch
things below that.
But I can't go through that kind
of thing, so the compiler
basically treats that as, I
can't touch that barrier.
And that [UNINTELLIGIBLE] means
the amount of stuff that
the compiler can do is
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So one way to do that
is basically inline.
On a max function, it's pretty
simple to inline.
Basically you can define a macro
that the CE front end
will go inline for you.
So this is simple.
Or you can define inline method
in here and put it in
the same file, and then we will
tell the compiler, look,
go and try doing inline
listening, and by doing that
we are forcing the compiler, or
telling it the ability to
inline, and they're not only
getting rid of the overhead of
the method calls, but also
you're letting the compiler a
lot more opportunity to go and
do something interesting.
So here's something you'll
find in many
streaming type programs.
What you do is you run through
a loop, reading through a
bunch of data, do
some processing
and writing it back.
And then you want to get the
data you wrote back, read it
again, do some processing
and write it back.
The problem in that this one
is the first loop which
stretches through all data.
So by the time I'm done with the
first loop I have written
all the data and the thing I
wrote early is probably all
the way down in my
cache hierarchy.
Because I wrote a huge amount
and it doesn't count it in my
cache so it goes down, down,
down, and the next guy has to
read it all the way
from bottom up.
So [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
means instead of doing that what
you can do is run for a
small amount of data.
So don't run the entire
data set.
Run a small amount of data,
write it into a buffer in the
middle that we know sit in the
cache, and the disk guys picks
up the buffer and finish it
up and write it back.
So by keeping the data in the
buffers what they have done is
between these two I actually
had some nice locality.
I can keep the data up.
So as we go into memory systems
and stuff like that
these kind of patterns
come up a lot.
Ah ha.
Tail recursion elimination.
So here there are many functions
that the last thing
you do is call itself.
OK?
This is pretty expensive because
what normally happens
is when you call a function you
set up a calling contest,
you do all this context
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
put things into the stack and
go, but you don't need to keep
instead because you're basically
done with the
previous guy.
You're just calling just to
go create another stack.
In a lot of these cases you can
reformulate the problem
into nice loop that has
no function calls.
So, in here, when you're doing
factorial, you can actually
formulate the factorial in a way
that you don't have to do
a function call.
So a lot of times if you end
up in a situation that the
last thing you do in some part
is the call itself and if
you're not doing anything
afterwards, you can always end
up in a situation where you
don't know how do that, you
can actually convert it into
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] loop.
And by doing this I got rid of
all my calling overhead and
stuff that I'm just starting
a nice tight loop.
OK?
So if you have patterns that
look like that you can think,
OK, look, this is nice,
I thought through
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
I got this there.
But now I can [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
transform it to more iterative
way of executing.
In many cases you will find
a way of doing that.
OK, then there are a bunch
of expression rules.
So a lot of times you have this
computation that if you
think carefully you can let
the preprocessor do in
something like calculate
something like that, if I know
what [UNINTELLIGIBLE] are, stuff
like that, I can just
put it in as a constant and
voila I don't even have to pay
any cost to compute it because
by the time it's compiled all
the computing is done.
And there are a lot of good
cases you can just get rid of
work by giving it to
the preprocessor.
I'm just calling sin(a) and
sin(a) twice in here, and the
sin(a) squared I just basically,
the compiler
probably won't know that the
sine every time you give it
the same number, you give it
the same same input, it's a
function, I think the compiler
doesn't know that, and this is
something you probably have
to do for the compiler.
Especially when you know the
function has no side effects.
This is a little bit more funky,
so assume I do two
similar computations, you might
want to do them together
as a single computation that
gives the compiler more
opportunity, but that means you
relay the function like a
sine, cosine, s of 1 function.
It's a little bit of funky thing
that in this list of
interesting things to do.
But I put it there because there
might be cases you might
find that's interesting, like if
you're doing taking min and
max, it might be calling
min and max separated.
You might be able to
call it together.
So the last set of rules
is parallelism rules.
Of course, we are going to visit
parallelism like crazy
in this class, but today we will
just go through some very
high level stuff to give you a
little bit of feel for what
can be done.
So I have this rule,
this program.
So what's wrong with
this program?
Why would this program
run very slow?
Can anybody tell me?
Why can't, in this program, I
can't do the full utilization
of my machine.
The problem in this program is
every iteration until this
condition is calculated I can't
start calculating this.
And so every iteration I had
of it, this is finished,
condition calculated,
and [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and new calculate that.
And once that's done, you go
to the next iteration.
We go to next iteration.
So by doing this I can't
do too much work.
On the other hand, if I can
unroll the loop like two times
and have two different
conditions, now I can do this
condition and these conditions,
and these two can
be done in parallel and when
these two get resolved I can
do these two operations.
So instead of doing xmax, I'm
operating two different
variables and at the end
I can resolve that.
So what I'm doing is
I'm calculating
two things in there.
And they go to four things,
whatever, to
keep the machine busy.
And each of them can be
calculated independently.
OK, so I can get parallelism
and at the end of the day I
can do that to help when I'm
summing something or whatever.
Do you see this?
So to get the six instruction
issued at a time, something
like that will give you more
abilities because there's more
things that can run
in parallel.
So most of the time it will be
good to see whether you can
eliminate these kind of chains
like here xmax is a chain
because xmax--
until the previous is calculated
I can't calculate
the next one, until that so I
have this chain that until
this is calculated I can't do
this, until this is done I
can't do the next iteration, so
xmax is kind of keeping me
very sequential.
By doing that I have two
things I can calculate.
So other interesting things is
if you are doing through this
kind of data structure
link list.
Sometimes if you have I believe
the bypass have
another point that points couple
of things ahead then I
can keep multiple of
them going on.
So I can do sort of waiting
for the next one I can
basically switch two elements,
do that so the next one I can
get some parallelism in here so
I can do things like that.
So to get some basic parallel
performance going on.
And this is basic kind of a
little bit of a data structure
augmentation.
You add additional data
make it run faster.
And you want to get all
your loops vectorized.
That means you want to run
things like assembly
instruction.
If you're using 32 bits, you
want to put a couple of them
together, run in
one SIMD unit.
But I don't want any of
you guys to go write
assembly to do this.
It's going to be a big pain to
write all the SIMD assembly.
We are not talking about
assembly but most the
compiler, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
compiler is somewhat
good at doing it.
So what this means is you're
kind of really nudge the
compiler, look at bunch of
compiler frags to get the
compiler to do it.
Sometimes it's--
when we go more into it, we'll
figure out how we can do it
looking at given the right flags
to compiler, sometimes
chaining the program a
little bit makes it
easier for the compiler.
So sometimes just wrestling with
the compiler, that's much
more easier, believe me, than
trying to do it by yourself.
By doing that you can get some
interesting performance.
And we will talk a lot more
about this coarse grain
parallelism and we have a bunch
of lectures on that.
Trying to figure out how to get
multicores, each core do
something parallel, and get
all your [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in the machine working
for at a given time
then only one guy.
And so here's an interesting
situation.
So I have this problem here.
Can I run this parallel?
So what I'm doing is I'm doing
these two loops and I'm adding
all the elements of
an array to total.
Is this parallel?
Can I run anything or any of
these things parallel?
Somebody says, yes, no,
whatever, what do you think?
Take a stand.
OK, what do you think?
AUDIENCE: I think yes.
PROFESSOR: Somebody
says yes, good.
Yes, takers, no takers.
Yes, everybody says yes.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is parallel.
But look at here, what happens
is previous total is needed to
calculate the next total, so how
can I run this parallel?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
for loop jumps every two.
PROFESSOR: OK, so she's somewhat
onto it, so let me
show you what we can do.
One thing you can do is instead
of calculating one
total for each basically
column, you can
calculate its own total.
OK?
So what happens is so for this
i's row, j's column.
So for each row, so each row
gets a different total, a temp
total, and so what that means
is you can calculate all the
columns total separately.
You can total all the columns,
and then total up those values
to get the full total.
So totalling up columns can be
done parallel because now all
of these things can be done
parallel because it's
totalling up two different,
multiple different values.
So it's kind of what she said
but you do it for each row
separately.
And so here's something, you
made the program a little bit
more complicated.
Actually for a sequence it run a
little bit slower but at the
end of the day you actually
get the program
parallelizable.
So a lot of times when you're
parallelizing is to also
looking at that algorithm little
bit changes to the
program that at the beginning
might look like you're slowing
down the program but ending
up getting good parallel
performance.
So a lot of parallelism
looks like this.
So here's the entire list of
things we talked about.
It's out there so you can go
look at them and see if you
understand them better.
And I'm leaving you with this
example that I'm not going to
have time to go through. which
is my program of a traveling
salesman problem.
So what you're doing is you're
looking at a way for a
tradesman to travel to
all of the city's
with a minimum cost.
Of course the minimum shortest
thing is exponential algorithm
so you don't do that.
There's a good heuristic, that
the greedy heuristic every
time you go to the city you go
to the cheapest city that's
not visited and you just jump
around and that's seem to be
pretty good heuristic.
And so I call this up, and I
will go to the end and then
just finish it up.
Oops, I went too far.
So what I did was I have eight
different stages basically,
each stage I did some changes
and then I got this program to
run about five times faster
than from where I started.
So you will see at each
stage what I did.
So this is basically out of the
menu of things I showed
you I found an instance I can
do and in this program I got
five times faster.
This is more normal than the
300 [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
I got [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and that's a real extreme
case, but enjoy
looking at this code.